let's say you're some type of traffic
engineer and what you're trying to
figure out is how many cars pass by a
certain point on the street at any given
point in time and you want to figure out
the probabilities that 100 cars pass or
five cars pass in a given hour so a good
place to start is just to define a
random variable that that essentially
represents what you care about so let's
say the number of cars of cars that pass
in some amount of time let's say in an
hour in an hour and your goal is to
figure out the probability distribution
of this random variable and then once
you know the probability distribution
then you can figure out you know what's
the probability that 100 cars pass in an
hour or the problem is that no cars pass
an hour and you'd be unstoppable
so and just to a little aside just to
move forward in this video there's two
assumptions we need to make because
we're going to study the process on
distribution in order to study it
there's two assumptions we have to make
that any hour on at this point on the
street is no different than any other
hour and we know that that's probably
false during rush hour in a real
situation you probably would have more
cars and in another rush hour and you
know if you wanted to be more realistic
maybe we do it in a day right because in
a day any period of time actually no I
shouldn't do a day where we have to
assume that every hour is completely you
just like any other hour and actually
even within the hour there's really no
differentiation from one second to the
other in terms of the probabilities that
a car arrives so that's a little bit of
a simplifying assumption that might not
truly apply to traffic but I think we
can we can make that assumption and the
other assumption we need to make is that
if a bunch of cars passed in one hour
that doesn't mean that fewer cars will
pass in the next that in no way does the
number of cars that pass in one period
effect or you know correlate or somehow
influence the number of cars that pass
in the next set they're really
independent given that we can then at
least try using the skills we have to
model out some type of a distribution
the first thing you do and I'd recommend
doing this for any distribution is that
you know figure maybe we can estimate
the mean let's sit out on that curb and
measure what this variable is over a
bunch of hours and then average it up
and that's going to be a pretty good
estimator for the actual mean of our
population or since it's a random
variable the expected value of this
random
let's say you do that and you get your
best estimate of the expected value the
expected value of this random variable
is I'll use the letter lambda so this
could be you know this could be nine
cars per hour you sat out there it could
be nine point three cars prior you sat
out there over hundreds of hours and you
just counted the number of cars each
hour and you averaged them all up you
said on average there are nine point
three cars per hour and you feel that's
a pretty good estimate so that's what
you have there and let's see what we
could do we know the binomial the
distribution right the binomial
distribution tells us that the expected
value of a random variable is equal to
the number of trials that that that
random variable is kind of composed of
right before in the previous videos we
were counting the number of heads in a
coin toss so this would be the number of
coin tosses times the probability of
success over each toss right this is
what we did with the binomial
distribution so maybe we can model our
traffic situation something similar this
is a number of cars that pass in an hour
right so maybe we could say you know
lambda cars per hour cars per hour is
equal to I don't know let's see let's
listen let's make each let's make each
experiment or each toss of the coin
equal to whether a car passes in a given
minute so there's 60 minutes per hour
and then so that there will be 60 trials
and then the probability that we have
success in each of those trials if we
model this as a binomial distribution
would be would be lambda over 60 cars
per minute and this would be a
probability this would be n and this
would be the probability if we said that
this is a binomial distribution and this
might actually this probably wouldn't be
that bad of an approximation if you
actually then said oh this is a binomial
distribution
so the probability the probability that
our random variable equals some given
value K you know the probability that
three cars exactly three cars pass in a
given hour it would then be equal to n
so n would be 60 choose K and you know I
three cars
times the probability of
so the probability that a car passes in
any minute so it would be lambda over 62
the number of successes we need so to
the K power times the probability of no
success or that no cars pass to the N
minus K right if we have K successes we
have to have 60 minus K failures there
are 60 minus K minutes where no car
passed you know this actually wouldn't
be that bad of an approximation where
you have 60 intervals and you say this
is a binomial distribution and and you
probably get reasonable results but
there's a core issue here in this model
where we model it as a binomial
distribution what happens if more than
one car passes in an hour right or more
than one car passes in a minute the way
we have it right now we call it a
success if one car passes in a minute
and if you're kind of counting it counts
as one success even if five cars pass in
that minute and so you say oh okay Sal I
know the solution there I just have to
get more granular instead of doing it
instead of dividing it into minutes
why don't I divide it into seconds so
the probability that I have K successes
I'll do instead of 60 intervals I'll do
3,600 intervals and so the probability
of K successful seconds so a second
where car is passing at that moment out
of 3,600 possible seconds so that's
3,600 choose K times the probability
that car passes in any given second well
that's the probability that's the
expected number of cars in an hour
divided by number of seconds in an hour
and we're going to have K successes and
then we're going to have and these are
the failures the probability of failure
you're going to have 3,600 minus K
failures and this would be even a better
approximation this actually would not be
so bad but still you have the situation
where you know two cars can come within
a half a second of each other and you
say okay so I see the pattern here we
just have to get more and more granular
we have to just make this number larger
and larger and larger and and your
intuition is correct and if you do that
you'll end up getting the Poisson
distribution and this is really
interesting cuz a lot of times people
give you the formula for the Prasad
distribution and you can kind of just
plug in the numbers and use it
it's neat to know that it really is just
the binomial distribution and the
binomial distribution really did come
from kind of the common sense of you
know flipping coins that's where
everything is coming from but before we
kind of prove that this if we take the
limit is let me change colors before we
prove that as we take the limit as this
number right here the number of
intervals approaches infinity that this
becomes the Poisson distribution I'm
going to make sure we have a couple of
of mathematical tools in our belt so the
first is something that you're probably
reasonably familiar with by now but I
just want to make sure that the limit as
X approaches infinity of one plus a over
X to the X power is equal to e to the a
X no no sorry is equal to e to the a and
I just do just to prove this to you
let's make a let's make a little
substitution here let's say that n is
equal to let me let me say 1 over N is
equal to a over X and then what would be
X would be X would be equal to n a right
x times 1 is equal to n times a and so
the limit is X approaches infinity as X
approaches infinity what is a approach a
is sorry as X approaches infinity with
an N approach well n is X divided by a
right so n would also approach infinity
so this thing would be the same thing as
just making our substitution the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 plus I
over X I made the substitution is 1 over
N and X is by this substitution n times
a and this is going to be the same thing
as the limit as n approaches infinity of
1 plus 1 over N to the N all of that to
the a and since there's no N out here we
could just take the limit of this and
then take that to the a power so that's
going to be equal to the limit as n
approaches infinity of 1 plus 1 over N
to the nth power all of that to the a
and this is our definition or one of the
ways to get to e if you watch the videos
on compound interest and all that this
is how we got to e and if you try it out
in your calculator just try larger and
larger ends here and you'll get e so
this is equal to this inner part is
equal to e so and we race to the eighth
power so it's equal to e to the a so
hopefully you're pretty satisfied that
this limit is equal to e to the a and
then one other toolkit I want in our
belt and I'll probably actually do the
proof in the next video the other
toolkit is to recognize that X factorial
let me do this X factorial over X minus
K factorial is equal to x times X minus
1 times X minus 2 all the way down 2
times X minus K plus 1 and we've done
this a lot of times but this is the most
abstract we've ever written it I can
give you a couple of sin and it will be
exactly just so you know they'll be
exactly K terms here 1 2 3 this is once
the first term second term third term
all the way and this is the K term and
this is important to our derivation of
the Poisson distribution but just to
make this in real numbers lets you know
if if if I had 7 factorial over 7 minus
2 factorial that's equal to 7 times 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
over 2 times
no sorry 7 minus 2 this is 5 so it's
over 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
these cancel out and you just have 7
times 6 and so it's 7 and then the last
term is 7 minus 2 plus 1 which is 6 7
minus 2 plus 1 and you had in this
example K was 2 and you had exactly two
terms so once we know those two things
were now ready to derive the Poisson
distribution and I'll do that in the in
the next video see you soon